oh
my god look
at this hi felix friendly mod slave here
this sub is actually seventh in terms of
traffic
on reddit top 10 [ __ ]
yeah so we may be 83 in subscribers
but we seven oh in post per day that
just means spam
ah come on you got me all excited
posting vote eight
okay that's cool never mind
that's so dope thank you everyone uh
i never expected this subreddit to go
anywhere because i have no faith in you
guys whatsoever
but this is just really cool amazing
congrats guys
leave your memes on the reddit
[Music]
episode oh god oh no need he say it a
third time
just buy a nokia no one cares just buy a
[ __ ] no
no yeah no one gives a [ __ ] just [ __ ]
scuff and scaffold nokia in your
that no one cares about see i upped it
up the third time
it was deliberate it was intentional
this is why
reposting exists because people forget
about the memes
no wait don't post that one i'll be back
i'll be back in 2021
to post it again don't you worry my
beard will be slightly longer
and i will be swearing a little bit more
epic oh god that's so embarrassing jesus
christ
oh my god yes this proves that repos are
in fact the best method of farming karma
he's gotten quite a bit aggressive over
the past year
because floor game this proves how his
principles didn't change
he's still the man we all know that's
right an idiot
that can't remember what he did a year
ago next meme
felix been talking about simps you
effing donkey meanwhile 20 year old
felix moving to italy to meet a girl he
met online
i am going on adventure yeah so what
did i review this meme already oh god i
can't remember
what are the memes help me
when the swedish man travels 1219 miles
to meet an
internet girl in italy look at that
don't use my own memes against me that's
illegal
stop it it's not simping if you get
married those are the rules
okay i was a simp until then
i'm willing to admit it i'm willing to
admit how problematic and much issue
but yes no symp no more no no more
all right we got an intro it took me
three generations
this is their original intro oh
yes
can we get a 24-hour version
[Music]
nice nice
top notch well done
[Music]
you know what you get it you get a temp
you got a tambourine smack
because that was amazing well done
today i am officially a 19 year old so i
baked a pewdiepie
shaker kick nice
happy birthday man official 19 year old
a respectable age i must say he said top
comments guests to decide come on reddit
do your
thing damn okay
okay is that real i want it i'll buy it
all right give me one sec
what a google jojo ass mousepad oh wow
there's
there's even better versions huh there
it is
where can i buy this oh of course
paulina ref gets one
it's ships from china dude it's gonna
take forever
oh my god it's the guy from the rio
movie
i got so many comments about who this
guy looks like
sideshow bob is that his name my son now
thinks coco
ellen videos are pewdiepie
you trained your son well oh good job um
um
girl's buying shampoo it has vitamins
rich oil proteins for my hair and good
puppy
it says shampoo oh my god this is so
true stupid girls in this stupid shampoo
am i right
cringe it has a bit in there and the
orange gotta send its essential oils so
there must be attention because it's set
essential in the name uh two plus
one is three one plus one is
come on man come
it doesn't have it anymore it's gone i
can't it doesn't have it
apologize god damn it
i'm not okay with this you guys are a
bunch of meanies
pewds in 50 years how's it going my
nephews
my name is grandpa
[Music]
yeah why not sure why not
i'll keep making videos if you guys keep
watching my style
oh hell yeah oh [ __ ] yeah that's so dumb
fitness and firm gravity falls steven
universe
shara what the [ __ ] is that adventure
time
dope oh look a little egg give me these
little antennas
that's so cute i like women reddit look
at that simp
i don't like women reddit i don't know
man seems kind of gay to me
can there be a middle crowd nah why
don't we let this childish memes
stop here okay no more symptoms no more
simp that
okay i guess the car the song is
copyrighted but okay
bring back green screen is it time has
it been so long already
okay all right i'll bring back green
screen i swear every time pewdiepie
grows a beard he descends a little
further into
insanity sorry that was just disgusting
i'm sorry
damn oh
hell yeah 80s anime
beautiful that's so cute oh it says
there joey quarter though
joe when carter i can't read sorry
[Applause]
oh god it keeps happening
i made a little mosaic of pewdiepie and
his fame god
damn uh
yeah i changed meme out of my anger see
i got a dog in set why are they ads on
this subreddit now what the [ __ ] is
happening
might say a fan art pierce fan hurt
seems about accurate
i would pick p no i see it's me
good good source image right there i am
not a simp you're right you're
not just a simp you're the biggest simp
god
damn confirmed
sigh kinda cringe bro
uh beldelphine called you simp cringe
bro
that's like getting simp tattooed on
your forehead my dude
oh god oh god what are you gonna do now
say
oh mr beast donated ten thousand keep up
the great stream
look at that simp look at him
disgusting sorry mr beast but what the
[ __ ] dude donating to a girl
disgusting why would you do that bro
i thought we were cool man
giving cyber an empty template to
explain himself
yes i've see we give you a chance to
get some redemption explain yourself
we're waiting don't take too long now
honestly though guys i would love to
give you guys a full explanation but
i've already done so alright check out
your video
but don't watch it right now all right
continue to watch this video
okay because otherwise i probably won't
have any food but tonight so please
please please guys i'm begging you
continue to watch the rest of this
lawyer
please hmm okay then
i see how it is scythe seeing his boss
and all of his fans call
him us
and build their feet too look at that
simp
damn respectable
my girlfriend did some pewdiepie fan art
and she was too shy to post it here big
pp oh i'm sorry is that pewdiepie
because i don't see the pewdiepies uh
i mean it's great it's amazing but uh no
no i hate it
meanwhile in an alternate universe
special box
i was gender gender bender version got
it
[Laughter]
so confusing what the [ __ ] that
we got a text our parents got a text
message to eat more vegetables
and fruits some of you will understand
that reference
damn oh my god
what am i looking at i wanted to make a
fine art for pizza for a long time and
here it is i hope you to
see it and like i love it are you
wearing boots no
what am i looking at what is edgar
wearing oh of course
i need that hat that merch why i need
you guys to design my merch
because every time you guys draw it it
looks so cool hit me up
cirrus van peepee sarah that's when
peepee nice
nice uh fellas if your girl is blonde
has blue eyes
just cooking videos that's not your girl
that's gordon ramsay she's all right god
[ __ ]
damn it rare sorry
i'm sorry i am so sorry that was worse
than scythe being a symp
i'm not a simp you're right you're not
just a save you're the biggest sin
it's even funnier the second time yeah
meanwhile i'm editing this video
god damn it
fine i'll keep i will edit but i will
not add in the cool effects that i
usually do in this video
we're just playing side it's a joke god
you're not gonna be so up
sheesh pewdiepie fan art too this one is
crazy i just hope
he finds this one why is there come on
me to the moon baby
no we're gonna pierce the moon it's
gonna go through the moon
not to the moon cringe very cool fan art
though but uh
i will not rate big peepee next level is
the underground
gang floor gang level 90. bless gg
blurs jenga oh god no
i will accept my fate that's so cool why
did this not
get more upvotes stop
these [ __ ] cooking [ __ ] stop doing it
bro those cats though damn sweden's lund
university is fed up of indians mocking
his name online
lund indian term use for peepee well
what's even funnier is that the whole
city is called lund
so pp
anniversary or university okay i got it
what else is stern then you can visit
the peepee cathedral
cathedral the pp botanical garden or
peepee historical museum
that's pretty cool ooh peepee water park
that's pretty cool satisfying pewdiepie
animation
damn can i use that that's so cool
that'd be really cool to use for live
streams can i please please please
please
[Laughter]
once the cocoa melon water is over we
gather all the animators that made the
intros and make a pewdiepie
anime episode that is so cool
everyone animates like five seconds
no pity chat no
what's with me in microphones man
that's very cool huge pp proud of you
one tambourine hit i'm gonna cut my left
testicle if leafy comes back
i guess i'm back or something less left
testicle
guess it's me and the mustache man now
okay fine i'll do it you know what i
didn't expect him to come back
and you know what i didn't expect him to
do so god damn well as well god damn it
i was trying to be edgy and be like he's
never coming back fine
i cut it off who wants it should i send
it to leafy tell us something your mom
doesn't know
he's earned it
[Laughter]
they should have simon felix in a video
together you're down for
i don't know if i collab with simp but
uh
i collide with anyone with that chair so
yes i'm if you're up for it
let's do it tambourina's spoken
the only simply except except i'm going
to sing a song for you marcia look at
that [ __ ] not a sim come on
when it's 4 am and you press restart
instead of shut down yeah that seems
about right
i'm leaving for the army i will miss you
pewds
for being a big part of my childhood i'm
going to basic training in uh
september 1st and uh thank you for being
a big part of my childhood
no problem i do that's good go into that
training and then we'll kill ceiling
gang
it's going to be a while till i can see
your videos again see you later
i tambourine salute you sir come back
stronger than ever come back 20 muscle
increase at least
pewdiepie would not be found attractive
in a lot of circles
uh that's what you're wrong [ __ ]
back in 2015 when i met pearce hey
dope very dope that is in
san francisco am i right you're probably
taller than pewds now
don't make me hurt tambourine there was
a rent that uh
it was at a school or something that was
fun i missed during meetups it's always
fun
but i hope i can do it that again oh hey
epic announcement that will probably get
taken out of context in media
and everyone will judge me and i don't
give a sh i've decided
no more selfies please listen to what i
the whole sentence though it's a it's
like um remember we used to have like a
passcode so like
i noticed if there's an actual fan that
wants to take a photo of me and i'm i'm
cool with it
how do i explain this i'm trying to
explain this so it doesn't get taken out
of context for media to just go like
he doesn't care about his fans i love
meeting
you guys that's the thing like i love
doing these meetups
where it's a set place to hang out and
just talk
and and meet up and get a chance to meet
you guys i think that's always something
i really love doing but
i think my life has just become to a
point where whenever i go outside i have
to just be ready
whatever i'm doing uh to just stop
and take a photo and i don't mind just
to stop and chat with you guys but the
whole photo process to me
i don't i don't like it you do like
10 000 of them and after a while you
just feel like you're an
animal at a zoo that's like a prop for
someone
and i don't i don't like it i'm tired of
it
i don't want to do it anymore so don't
misunderstand me like if you meet me i
would love to
meet you like chat quick whatever but
i don't want to take a photo i'm done
i know that's hard for people to
understand and i don't expect everyone
to understand
this is something i decided so i can
feel more comfortable going out in
public because i'm kinda
i kind of feel weird about always being
ready to take a photo with someone
and there's a lot of other layers to it
as well with that
i don't always want people to know where
i am
you know if everyone just took their
photo and
didn't share it fine but the problem is
people share it online and then people
other people online see it and they're
like oh there he's there what is he
doing there and
yeah yeah i feel like i always have to
it's so uncomfortable and
like you meet a fan that's outside your
house and you don't really want to say
hey can we not do a photo because i
actually live here
because you don't want them to know that
you actually live there
it's so hard to explain these things uh
there's a lot of nuances to it and in
general i think the main thing is i just
don't i just don't like it
and i think my audience respect me
enough to understand that uh
i'm happy to do a selfie if it's an at a
meeting meeting
and greet place or whatever because it's
a different context but when i'm out in
public
it's just uh it's just gotten to a point
where it feels dehumanizing and i don't
enjoy
being in public anymore because of it so
i decided
uh for my own sake i'm not doing it
anymore i might change my mind in the
future but
i already feel better with this decision
so thank you for understanding
god damn
i used to twelve thousand dollar motion
capture suit
for this super hot themed pewdiepie no
you did not
[Music]
press subscribe to continue and unsub
from coco melon
oh god it's a stickman now goddammit
god damn it look at that shrimp good
joke
good joke you got a very light
tambourine hit
well done girlfriend can and will cheat
on you very expensive it's an amphibian
has messy hair not a frog frog will
never cheat on you
just one food born amphibian has no hair
a frog as an as an old well i guess i
had a toad
i can confirm this is all true honestly
having marzia kind of cringe compared to
slippy
rest in peace sleepy song
ah
[Laughter]
well it made me laugh that's amazing
are you winning son oh it's my dad holy
sh
[Music]
this is so meta
[Music]
boom boom boom very nice i like uh there
are 103 millions
of million of felix subscribers that are
not on this subreddit
subscribe to the subreddit we gotta get
number one baby
we look the same yes we have to do
something about it
god damn it
my beard will grow to the floor so i'm
always connected to the floor and my
tambourine
will grow to the moon me listening to my
own jokes
other people listening to my jokes
nice scythe is a simp no [ __ ] way did
she do that that's hilarious
animals are not our friends sven said
swim noises
oh no i gotta play minecraft this week i
gotta play minecraft this week i cannot
wait any longer
belle del fin or something oh nice
i am not just sad
that's how you know that's how you know
let's appreciate
sibe all right let's do that let's
finish up with some
side appreciation look at that good
editor well done side thank you
even though you're simp you're a great
editor and there's nothing shame today
that's amazing jesus christ huge pp
favorite new thing scratch haunting
things into bananas at the market
so when people take them home hours
later the words appear and they think a
ghost knows it's secret
jesus christ that's terrifying holy [ __ ]
what how is this not higher voted jesus
christ
is there time lapse of this yeah
damn holy oh
oh my god it hurts to look at i don't
know why
damn it's like he's pooping them out
hell yeah the portrait is it took five
hours
well done huge pp don't also please
don't
misunderstand i love you guys so much
you're like a
father to me okay but uh yes
that's the rules rules are rules epic
see you guys tomorrow thank you for
watching
halo children of
nine parts
time to raise what was once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
well